americran is taking hold as china gears
up to host the beijing winter olympics
next month
the country recorded its first local
case of omrikron in the port city of
tianjin just 30 minutes away from
beijing igniting a lockdown and mass
testing of 14 million people
annyang a city of 5 million people
became the second city to be fully
locked down a day after detecting
americran in the central hernan province
elsewhere shenzhen is advising residents
against travel
jung-joo has required city-wide testing
and xi'an has confined some of its 13
million residents to their homes since
before christmas
china's commitment to its covet zero
policy has managed to keep domestic
infections at near zero since the virus
first emerged from wuhan
omicron is of massive concern to china
and that's because
increasingly stringent measures have
failed to stamp out the delta variant
the country is witnessing new flare-ups
sprouting up in one place and before the
authorities can quote it springing up in
another
china's vaccines are another glaring
worry
more than 86 percent of china's 1.4
billion people have been fully
vaccinated but the country still relies
heavily on border closures and stringent
domestic curbs to keep the virus at bay
with less protection from domestic
vaccines and a population that has
little natural immunity to covet china
is particularly vulnerable to the virus
how well the chinese
and cyanopharm vaccines were working
against variants wasn't immediately
clear
different countries reported wildly
different efficacies early on and
studies show that they may not provide
adequate protection against amrikron
there's also the question about the
health risks that omicron presents the
omercon variant may be less severe than
earlier mutations but it's also a lot
more transmissible just a small number
of cases could test the limits of the
country's healthcare system
[Music]
china may want to wait until it's
confident in its virus control measures
before it opens up but omnicron and
other variants to come may have
different plans
[Music]